what's up reject nation
I'm Greg I'm John we watched the comedy
yes the political comedy the r-rated
family comedy the conspiracy thriller
irresistible written and directed by the
former Daily Show host Jon Stewart oh
yeah
starring Steve Carell II Chris Cooper
and Rose Byrne is that Mackenzie Davis I
haven't looked at the IMDB yes yeah
there's a Will Sasso in there they're
young people who show up we actually
watch this on the service row wait so
thanks for a sponsored video ro8 I
actually really like this streaming
service a lot I was my mom's birthday
this week and as a treat we rented Scoob
off of row II for her because I told her
in the first half hour if you don't like
this you can return it and replace it
for something else movie love guarantee
and she did they watch birds of prey
instead courtesy a ro8 if you guys do
want to rent this movie it's $2 off this
specific rental you use the link at the
description box link and pin comment as
well they have a lot of great deals a
dollar 50 off your first rental buck off
Tuesday where you save a dollar off of
all new releases all day happy hour from
midnight to 3:00 p.m. really recommend
ro8 I've been using them on my own so
give them a shot I think it's well worth
it even if it's this you don't want to
watch you just go through their
selection they got plenty of last summer
movies starting at $1 no need to
oversell it alright I use the service
it's good enough for that I believe
double toast has been working with them
as well there's a reason why so
irresistible written and directed by Jon
Stewart here is the plot pitched on IMDB
a Democratic strategist played by Steve
Carell helps a retired veteran played by
Chris Cooper run for mayor in a small
conservative Midwest town things really
kick in a high gear when his Republican
strategist rival Rose Byrne steps into
the picture to try to
in this campaign so the main thing I was
looking forward to before watching this
movie was Steve Carell's performance
because Steve Carell he came from The
Daily Show with Jon Stewart the fact of
them reuniting together sounded like a
really fun time and I was like at least
that should be good so really good
positive I can tell you is that Steve
Carell's performance is really good all
the performances all around are pretty
solid Rose Byrne it was fun seeing her
embody a villainous character again I
think there's a big laugh that I got
from her that's actually in the trailer
Chris Cooper turns in a really sincere
performance I gotta say it's a very
earnest very sincere performance here's
what I like about it I like what it's
commentating on the messages is trying
to convey that's like the main jazz that
I really did enjoy like this movie
really is setting out to expose the
manipulation that happens within the
voting system of course a lot of talks
about a financial side of things lack of
regulation and super PACs in the way
that basically big Washington political
folks will swoop in on small towns for
the notoriety and to help their bigger
bottom line and then vacate them and not
actually demonstrate any care or or
follow through on their promises yeah
there's a there's a lot that it wants to
explore in this movie I'd say that if
this movie knew its tone this could have
been a very impactful film yeah cuz it
wants to be like a Barry Levinson type
of comedy like a wag of the dog one of
those political comedies write to me at
least this is how it registered when I
was watching it is that Jon Stewart has
a lot on his mind
ideally I think that when you hear Jon
Stewart's writing and directing this
movie these are the kind of topics are
probably gonna want him to cover right
I'm assuming that's what people would
want from the guy and his first movie
was pretty decently received to the
movie especially in the first half I
didn't feel like the comedy felt natural
they actually seemed like I have a lot
of want to talk about but people
probably won't listen unless the movie's
a comedy yeah and I think this movie
probably would work better as a dramedy
with a little bit more emphasis on the
comedy side but instead of pitching this
as a comedy kind of puts it in this
weird land of the real problematic tonal
issues well yeah because
the problem is it's torn between a few
different kinds of comedy it doesn't
seem to know whether it wants to be a
you know family a small-town wholesome
comedy or whether it wants to be a
satire or of a broad farce at times like
there are a couple moments especially
where I found myself truly disoriented
by like a new scene turning up with a
random scenario in it that doesn't seem
to fit the rest of the rules of the
movie or whatever no because there are
scenes where it seemed like okay maybe
this is more like the grounded take
where it's like the Judd Apatow like
banter with a bit of a heightened
surreal quality to it then there are
times where it's like this is so
cartoony like weird like there's this
thing where a cyborg yeah this guy in
this full body like mechanized brace
suit and I was sitting there going is
this a real person is this a reference
is this some kind of farcical creation
that you've done to demonstrate
something that I'm not quite catching
here really the main issue with this
movie was I don't think it knew how to
make its comedy really work out of a
hour and 40 minute movie I can count on
one hand the amount of times like there
was one time I really laughed like
really laughed like pretty hard that was
way late into the movie and there were a
couple times where I you know I laughed
I laughed half the time because I
thought it was funny and half the time
because I was like I'm a little confused
by let's have the movies comedy clicks a
lot better Andrews I'm talking so much
about the comic cuz that's like the
biggest flaw with this movie actually
starts clicking a lot better especially
tonally once Rose burns character steps
into this town because she just really
loves she's the Integris in the movie
and her main thing is she loves to
antagonize Steve Carell and she doesn't
need to be here like her character
doesn't need to be here she's just here
to ruin Steve Carell is life and when
that stuff starts picking up a lot of
momentum and the stakes start being
raised to where it really is like okay
how will Steve Carell team beat their
opponent the guy who's been mayor in
this city for 40 years or whatever how
can they pull this off that's when like
that with the stakes combined with some
scenes of like there's this one moment
where Steve Carell makes an ass out of
himself going off on someone you might
know
everything and it's so like oh there's
some cringe in this movie cringy but
then it ends up being the funniest scene
in the whole movie to me the movie can
be very charming and what it's talking
about I think is really great stuff it
sets itself up to be like this
Republican hate movie right that's what
that's what it comes across like don't
get me wrong
it starts off that way like the first
half of the movie is really liked
Democratic up here yeah I got a good
worried you're following this guy who's
like we're gonna rebrand the party with
this dude and the town is a conservative
state I think Chris if I'm remembering
correctly Chris Cooper's character is
set up in a way where he is probably
identifies his Republican and they want
to make him a Democrat yeah he
demonstrates some ideals in this viral
video that are clearly not trademarked
Republican ideals as the movie
progresses though it really starts
uncovering the dark side like I said
earlier in this video of the like the
voting system and showing that hey and
the campaigning process overall and on
the Democratic side there's a lot of
corruption there yeah this movie zeroes
in on the amount of spin and the way the
divide truly between Steve Carell and
his Washington team and the actual folks
in the town and there's a lot in this
movie that plays on his obliviousness to
them what I liked too about the movie is
Steve Carell he gives an earnest
performance and there are times where
his character is a total [ __ ] like
he's he's very condescending yeah
evidently he just thinks he's better
than everyone yeah he's he's looking
down on the small-town stereo and he
looks down on his team too you know it
seems like the movies setting up for
this really obvious arc but it isn't
quite ammeter it's that you get this
really interesting twist when I say
conspiracy thriller you will not predict
it I don't think you will you won't
doesn't set you up for it
you you might get their seeds there
there are seeds there yeah there are
things where if you don't use the movie
love and switch it out after a half hour
there are things that will pay off from
the early part of the movie that maybe
stood out as strange when the actual
true nature of the film reveals itself
and the thing is with that again that
cuts to the heart of yeah I like what
this movies about a lot and I like
ultimately what it did I just feel like
there's something odd in the way it
chose to present its point of view
because yeah you're going through Steve
Carell ends and yet it feels like the
movie
self wants to be from the townsfolk's
point of view and from their needs and
all that I feel like in executing that
they really kind of slide themselves and
not humanizing and spending more
character time with the folks in the
town you do get them they are
heartwarming but in terms of the actual
character depth you know you're mostly
with Steve Carell I mean this is not the
movies true protagonist the movie still
felt like Jon Stewart giving
observational comedy but not making a
movie lived in with its characters and
then letting the messages yeah sometimes
you do have to like make sure you're
getting your messages clear-cut across
Russia in a political comedy like this
you could just hear Jon Stewart's I'm
not even that knowledgeable of John
Stehr I'm not even I'm not even like
that big of a fan of surly I've always
liked his comedy and I've always liked
whatever I've caught of The Daily Show
but I never really was like religiously
watching that show or weekly even you
know so I'm not the biggest Jon Stewart
fanatic or something but watching it
there were things were especially in the
first half of this movie I was like I
don't think he wanted to make a comedy I
would wonder what the actual ideal
script was because it seems like
something that would have needed to
maybe be a little bit longer and go into
that big short territory where there is
rhythm there is comedy but there's also
a lot of political discourse it's a
little at odds with itself in terms of
how its presenting its point of view and
what its plot needs to do to sell
certain things I think that this could
have used a little more formulation in
the scripting and that would have maybe
helped the direction be a little more
consistent as it stands though I mean
there are a lot of really fun
performances and there are scenes and
moments that really work and yet what's
at the heart of the movie and there's
even an interesting little interview in
the end credits about the circumstances
of the movie that are worth you know
looking into if they're not the newest
news they're still you know worth
looking into well that's what I'll say
is what was working for me a little bit
better was when they did really play
with media in the last half those were
the few times they're really seem like
it knew what it was doing yeah I mean
that's the other thing that I love about
Jon Stewart as a human is like he's a he
seems like a great deal to talk about
yeah he's been active and he's been you
know do walk in the walks since the day
or so - like actually out campaigning
for various causes and
I love what his comedy represents in
terms of the movie I felt like ads with
itself with what kind of comedy this
wanted to be and that actually seems to
distract more from what it wants to talk
about yeah and so they kind of get
everything punching a little below its
weight because of that I'm not sure who
would like this or who would I don't
really don't know I don't know who this
would nail it for is that yeah cuz I
thought it was fine overall I would
steer towards I liked it I just also
can't help but be like it's also kind of
weird to also just in its actual
handling of certain concepts could have
been a little more clear a little more
pronounced I think it also is an
interesting just growth illustrator for
Jon Stewart as a writer director because
you know I haven't seen rosewater but
I've heard some reasonably decent things
about it better than I've heard about
this and so it seems like this is
illustrating at least some places he has
to grow in terms of you know cinematic
political comedy yeah because you know
where the daily show airs toward comedy
but is also you know very much about the
politics I felt like this could have
kind of done the opposite more
effectively being definitely comedic but
also very focused on you know the people
in the story and whatnot cuz there were
too much of Jon Stewart's talking to the
audience as opposed to just letting the
characters do the job and there was too
much of that yeah there were a lot of
moments where I would find myself like
predicting things or being like okay I
get what you're setting up here there
are a lot of things where you really get
what they're setting up and they don't
make up for that with the character now
you know I tell ya I don't I don't know
it's a strain or if you start watching
the first half-hour named for you return
it and get something out
did you see irresistible what's your
favorite Steve Carell thingy or Jon
Stewart thingy yeh subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell
thanks for away for sponsoring this
video catch you guys soon